hey parents do you need help with your
child's homework let me show you how
kigo can help with homework today so I'm
in kigo and I'm in the activities Tab
and I'm going to use the tutor me
feature so you all you have to do is you
or your child can copy and paste your
child's homework question into comigo
for example let's say I need some help
with this algebra problem can you help
me solve the equation for
x let's see what comigo
says
so you can see that cigo is going to
help me figure it out but it's not going
to just give me answers instead it's
going to guide me to find the answer
myself which is going to really help me
learn this concept so let's say I think
we need to solve for
x and it will encourage me it will give
me some tips on some other things that I
should consider to solve this problem
now if I go to chat GPT and I ask it to
help me with the same problem it's all
as you can see it's only going to give
me the answer but that might not
necessarily lead to my child really
developing deeper understanding and
learning of their homework so if you
want your kid to get homework help and
really understand the why behind the
answer kigo can help that's because we
built kigo with learning in mind so if
you want to give it a try yourself just
click the link in the description below
to get started with
Kamika